when ethiopian government troops took
control of the tigrayan regional capital
of mckelly
last month prime minister abi ahmed said
the law enforcement
operation against the tigrayan people's
liberation front or tplf
was over others said the conflict had
only just begun
abby said no civilians have been killed
by government troops
both sides have been accused of rights
abuses we've seen targeting
of civilians and civilian infrastructure
with heavy artillery fire
we have seen widespread looting of
private
property in in many towns in western
tigray
we've seen extra extrajudicial
executions of individuals
alleged to be linked to the tplf but
also
prominent business people we've
obviously also seen a context of
massive restrictions on humanitarian
access
the conflict has impacted the region
there are numerous reports of eritrean
soldiers operating into grey
eritreas and ethiopia's governments deny
it
more than 50 000 people have fled to
refugee camps in neighboring sudan
that's reignited an old border dispute
between the two countries
last week sudan accused ethiopian forces
of attacking its soldiers
inside its border and within ethiopia
there are an increasing number of
reports
of inter-ethnic violence in other parts
of the country
last week more than a hundred villagers
were killed by an armed group
in benishan gul gamuz region these type
of incidents have been
very very frequent uh in ethiopia uh
and does and those incidents have
claimed the lives of
dozens hundreds uh even thousands of
people so it really is a recurring theme
it has been a recurring theme for the
last six months or
or a month and that's the sad reality of
it
it was mass protests in different parts
of the country
that brought prime minister abby ahmed
to power nearly three years ago
before that decades of authoritarian
rule
had frozen generations old conflicts
many of them on ethnic lines
abby was credited with bringing in some
democratic reforms
that's led some of those conflicts to
start boiling over
his drive to unify ethiopia has
conflicted with growing demands of
various ethnic groups
who are seeking more autonomy when you
have over 100
ethnic groups in a country you have to
find ways of making things work
all right so abby's you know move
towards you know quote-unquote unity
is likely to cause more problems tplf is
just
one the tplf dominated the government
for nearly 30 years before abby took
over
one of the triggers of the conflict
integre was the postponement of
elections that were due
four months ago because of kovid
now they're expected to be held amid
growing tensions
in 2021 malcolm webb
al jazeera let's talk now to martin
plautz he's a fellow university of
london and horn of africa analyst he
joins us on skype from london martin
platt welcome back to the newshour
uh why did if he did why did the prime
minister abby ahmed misjudge this
situation
so horrendously
two reasons for this the first is that
he thought that
he had the force of the ethiopian
federal
uh army behind him an air force that the
tigrans couldn't possibly respond to
and that he had with him also amhara
militia
so he had a very powerful force and then
from the north
he had allies in eritrea who have also
become involved in this conflict
so he was essentially attacking from
three directions from the north
from the um east and from the south and
he thought he could crush the tigrans
the second one is that he is a
pentecostalist
and very much believes that positive
thought
is enough it will get you by so uh in a
sense there were there were two reasons
for this
do you think the tigrayans will carry on
pushing back
and if they try to can they sustain that
i think that's a very difficult question
to answer uh
the indications at the moment are that
there is still
fighting going on how long that will
continue for is impossible to tell
but they did have more than 100 maybe
150 000
men under arms and the tradition in
tigre
is to go into the hills and fight from
the hills not to try to hold the cities
so if they do that they have a long
history of doing it
and there's no reason why they could not
continue the big question
is what will sudan do because all their
supplies of
essentials like fuel and food and
ammunition
will need to come in from sudan can that
be sustained
will sudan allow that to be sustained
that we don't know
so clearly this maybe never started out
as a law enforcement operation that was
what it was labeled as
it sounds as if you're painting a
picture describing this descending
into almost a civil war
well it no it's not a civil war this is
an international war
you already have the eritreans involved
uh
the united states has made it clear that
they believe eritrean forces are
involved uh
britain uh sort of off the record
accepts that this is the case so do the
european union so there's little k
little in a little indication that's not
true eritrean forces
are involved so you are in this is now a
full-scale
war on three fronts um involving
more than one country that's terribly
dangerous
um for for the tigrans but also for
ethiopia because
they they also withdrew troops from
somalia
that destabilized somalia they pulled
people out of
other areas which are tense like benich
angle
which has now seen more than 100 people
dead with ethnic violence
now how much can that be laid on at the
door of abi ahmed
well i think quite a lot martin platt in
london
thanks very much